hi my name is John Mayor and I feel
accepted about being Conan O'Brien's
friend that's very nice like you're been
accepted into an elite club maybe the
most elite club in Show Business I have
always wanted to be before this became a
catchphrase I've wanted to be your
friend you know what interesting you
were very nice you came on the show many
times over the years and uh you'd always
say the nicest things you would do these
interviews and people would be saying to
me like John Mayor it's huge and they
would say oh he's in an interview that
where they're trying to talk to him
about music you would you would say nice
things about our show and what we were
trying to do so it's very nice I mean it
I mean I don't want to do the thing
where someone says like you never invite
me over Dave but but I have waited to be
on this podcast I've waited for you to
ask me to be on the podcast for a long
time not angrily but that's all to say
I'm excited to finally be here I just
want to say that everyone in this stream
has been here when they repeatedly come
in and say what about John Mayor and I
say Absol I say abs lutely not
I'm not having it I'm not a fan of this
guitar fellow what I always say not
a I'm thrilled you're here I am I thank
you and my acting assumption is that
people don't want to do it so I'm very
happy to have you so let's clear the air
on that and also clear the air on which
of us is the better musician oh because
that's a running debate no it's not no
nobody's debating oh I'm thinking of a
different debate yeah I'm thinking of
the famous Lin and Douglas debates which
I'm sorry I completely forgot cuz you're
a virtuoso thank you you you play from
the heart you play with
love no that's the way to put it that's
that you have a good personality well no
when it comes to playing the guitar I
have I play uh I play you play with
great intention I play with you play
with your
hands no you do you do you know what's
really funny is
I've always I've I've struggled it
throughout my life to to play the guitar
and one of my go-to songs was always Bob
dyan's buckets of rain that just I love
that song and I like to play it and I
like to sing it and I always started to
think you know I I think I play this one
pretty well and then there was a benefit
I don't know if you'll remember this I
remember but it might have I don't know
if it was like eight years or so ago and
you're on the benefit too and I do my
thing and then you come out and I have
no idea you're going to do this and you
start to say I'm going to play a Dylan
tune and you play buckets of rain
remember yeah I remember that and I went
home and I destroyed my
guitars and then I fed my hands into a
wood
chipper because it was it made such a
mockery of the one song I thought I
could really play with like feeling and
I I was like oh and it's that thing I'm
not even saleri looking at Mozart in
this I'm I'm a chamber poot looking at
saler who's looking at Mozart you know
it didn't make you want to go home and
get it more under your hands just it it
discouraged I just understood that I am
an ape who's on this Earth for so much
time and there's no amount of time left
where this ape is going to learn that
you know what I mean I just I feel that
way about so many things I I tried
standup comedy and I did the same thing
I go why would I want to be the the
33,000 best at something when I could
devote all my energies to be you know in
the top right right the in the
conversation of the top something there
a lot of things I love about wintertime
MH so cold outside you gather inside
with your Chums yeah your Bros highfive
them yeah and you sit around a crackling
fire and you know what you do what crack
open a cold one that's it isn't it
that's it it is it is it is y and when
you crack open a cold one you better
make sure it's Miller Light ah the best
one sit around there's a roaring fire
maybe we just roasted some chestnuts
probably not no one does that really no
then they crack open a Miller Light and
it makes the conversation kind of flow
everyone's happy you guys are talking
about sports we are talking about sports
we're talking about hockey we're talking
about uh highly we're talking about
trucks we're talking about cars we're
talking about things we enjoy and every
now and then we stop we high five and we
have some more Miller Light yeah and
then it's got that clean finish oh don't
even get me started on the clean finish
and it's only 96 calories 3.2 carbs per
12 oun again I did those calculations
millerite Great Taste 96 calories go to
millerlite.com to find out delivery
options near you you don't have to go to
the store delivery options or you can
pick up some mirror light pretty much
anywhere they sell beer if you walk in
and they sell beer my guess is they've
got Miller life celebrate responsibly
Miller Brewing Company Milwaukee W cunon
96 calories and 3.2 carbage per 12
ounces I don't know I guess I feel like
they're different maybe The Grass Is
Always Greener but I uh the the times
the many times that I've watched you
play and heard you play I I just and
I've heard you in interviews sort of
talk about like yeah I made a decision I
think you say you saw Michael J fox in
Back to the Future and you were like
okay I'm I guess I'll learn to do that
and I think no that's not how it happens
that is not you there's something
something else was there there's
something in you clearly that uh isn't
in other people and so it was it was
just very in a way it relaxed me cuz I
thought no I play the guitar because I
find it kind of calming for myself and I
try not to inflict it on too many other
people but um no I did not watch you and
say well I better really get at it now
okay so I have a story about the time I
was relaxed the way you just explained
it I was at a restaurant one night and
uh I was at Craigs not to brag I was at
Craigs and you got into Craigs I got
into Craigs I keep trying it's like you
on this podcast it just couldn't they
were like absolutely not but anyway go
ahead and Jeff Beck was in the room oh
Jesus and I was relaxed it's so funny to
hear you say that I went oh I don't have
to think about how I play the guitar
because the best is in the room and it's
not me in your mind it was it's it's I
was comforted I could finally quiet down
this noise in my head I didn't know was
there which is the best in the room is
sitting over there and it doesn't have
to be it doesn't have to maybe be me can
I ask you a question which is uh do you
when did this sighting happen I know
Jeff back past not too long ago it
wasn't that long it was probably 2018 or
something see this is something I think
some of this comes a little bit with
getting a little older you're still in
my book an incredibly young person but
but I think some of this came to me
later meaning the uh the ability to say
yeah that person's just so amazing and
I'm not going to worry about it oh I
have that I think that I don't know that
I had that in my 20s I was so you know
teens and 20s I was so hungry and then
there's this nice thing that comes later
on uh you know people malign getting old
and we have this whole culture that says
you know you oh my God that's terrible
and I'm especially in comedy that you
know I've turned 60 this year and I you
know I'm starting to get in my head a
little bit about it and then I thought
oh no I don't know I do what I can and
there's so many people that are so great
and I'm excited when I see how great
young young people are and they're when
I'm around like a Martin short I relax
cuz I go okay that's Martin Short I'm no
Martin Short that's Martin Short I have
that when I go to Hollywood parties
which I don't very often anymore but I
used to go to parties and see beautiful
women and think to myself I get
discouraged I get sad i' never even went
up to them and I'd get
sad and and now get sad why um I'd get
sad because I'd be so desirous of their
approval and their attention I would
just I remember being so young I'd want
to leave I don't even know what my
expectation was but it was to leave
walking on air or something to have
everybody just just sort of night me or
something at the party and now I walk in
and I don't mean this in any U sort of
um self-facing way I go and it's it's
freeing they don't give a right I
say this she doesn't give a it's
awesome because she doesn't and that's
great so I don't even think about it
they don't care I have always felt sad
for beautiful women cuz they're they
don't get to be with me oh Jee because
I'm taken you know what I mean and I
know I don't know what you me ask let me
just be really clear please they all go
their whole lives and not know uh the
orgasmic Beauty oh come on okay of being
with this spam skin skeleton I just have
an issue with you and orgasmic Beauty
being in the same
sentence